yeah welcome to this video a 15 minute
game and it seems that thou not many
players some in the pool right now you
cannot often see that from the rating
mismatches it tries to give you an
opponent of approximately your strength
but um you see that it didn't work out
this time so we've got the Kings Indian
four nights fr Paul attacking all night
speak for politic black have some some
options here c5 and night 86 mostly c5
is normally ads by D 5v5 so e five is a
bit uncommon you know where do you go
this happen you're probably g7 don't
think that he six some a big issue
otherwise it's very likely that if I've
was a bit premature why to spend lots of
time on poles for honest and dumb hasn't
developed okay I'll grab here Knight
takes d4 d5 has already a upon and after
knight c6 it will be difficult for him
to keep material d fibers under lots of
pressure and strategically speaking you
cannot really take on d6 takes rd 694
some strategically horrible giving up
the the bishop
if you give up the bishop in such a
structure you've got so many weaknesses
on dark squares especially III here it's
terrible yeah okay I need you take and
that it's it's excellent now the
question is how to how to proceed now I
can simply take on d6 which should be
okay the only am problem on the only
question is is there on even no more
powerful way to play on a noun procreate
or e 55 certainly not bad okay but I
want to quickly get the rukon the VA for
the e-file the pawn on d6 is no problem
at all yeah and now after you create
normal he cannot castle Queen B 6 wins
the night simply he's in a deadly pin
and if you cannot castle at sir yeah
well this I'm immediately runs in 2 nite
c 5 which looks like the useful news
anyway
mmm this is already a tricky for white
what's now the questions can you see is
he able to cancel I'm want to make sure
that he cannot really castle maybe this
one after castles I can take default
with check and e2 and maybe 95 I was
also possible now like an OS that big
trick pick trick 95 at the end naturally
if should be enough let's wrap this 95
where I can play on p6 everything else
fails rupee 6 i also have 497 also good
move yeah 95 97 s also possible
well no 95 hmm 95 was slightly tricky i
mean i can probably move the coin you
okay but now i have half the check to
cover c5 with with the temple and look
II ate probably threatening Queenie one
on h3 i can probably am sacrifice if he
attacks the the bishop yeah it should be
possible so it's too much i have them
the worker also ready to to join in
what's the quickest way to do that yeah
probably grabbed it first and how how to
signal 93 threatening um threatening on
f2 he's got Luke f1 the night f2 is made
okay yeah this is this is the easiest
night F to mate as the threat he doesn't
have a check on anything he needs to
protect it with rook f1 and then I have
the check rook takes rook e1 shag look
at one group text at one mate
yes this is made no way to stop that if
you go night d12 cover to this rupee one
made immediately he has no way to to
cover have to oops okay yep can more
preamble this so only only one move
possible white resigns yeah well not
especially an exciting game but it shows
clearly that you need to be cautious
with making many of those aggressive
porn moves it's a it there are lines
where it is possible but you really need
to know in detail what what's going on
here blonde white must play d5 and we
have sort of benoni set up black gum has
more than one idea but probably you will
play 60 taking the center and the game
we played this and after after 97 it is
very difficult or ready to to keep the
center together it's a very very heart
of you if you look at this what is
White's supposed to play I'm threatening
to take on d4 to win the poem let's say
makes nothing if i just take here and
with this motif when the pawn this is a
nice nice little trick on queen bee
eight I can recapture I hands check if I
want and of course you cannot take here
because the queen is hanging so you
cannot make zero move if you go d5 I
grab this which is probably relatively
speaking the best way to go
and after this in the game it's simply
losing a poem this way or after this
there's some galley it can also take n
play 96 it's not bad but after this
white is also in trouble we saw that in
the game this led to two big trouble
there this is this dark squares are
terribly weak also be too I think this
is probably not not defensible anymore
against a good player black yeah thanks
for watching